It feels that way. I mean,
it really does feel as though any common bonds that we want shared are basically
disintegrating and that you're being pressured into mimicking the belief that
all those bonds are gone.
So even if you believe that the bonds aren't really afraid and that really,
we should have some stuff in common. If you say that out loud,
you're part of the system, you're part of the white supremacist system. Uh,
and this is it. It's such dangerous stuff. And as we're sitting here very,
in the last few hours, there was a,
there was a sort of graphic that came out from the national museum of
African-American history and culture, which is a Smithsonian Institute,
taxpayer funded institution by the government funded by the government.
And it was all about whiteness and the evils whiteness,
and among the evils of whiteness things that we've all integrated into our lives
because of the prevailing system of white supremacy or things like hard work,
individualism, justice, time management,
delayed gratification, science. I'm not kidding. This is all in the document.
These are all of these are all things that are listed as elements of white
supremacy. That must be rejected in order to move forward into a better,
more progressive world.
I'm Dave Rubin. And this is the Rubin report. Quick reminder,
everybody to subscribe to our YouTube channel and click that notification bell,
especially,
especially on a day like today when I have a guest so dangerous
that we're going to get in a lot of trouble.
You understand the man sitting across me. That's right. It is Ben Shapiro,
author of the new book. How to destroy America in three easy steps.
Here we go again, my friend.
I know, just get ready for you. You gotta, you gotta worse than I do. I mean,
honestly, I'm okay. My people will be fine. Yeah. You're the one who pays them.
Do I get it worse than you? I'm not sure.
You have a very dedicated group of people at media matters who
sit and wait for you to nod or to move in a way
that they can imply is white supremacist. I have a,
I have a bunch of anonymous anime genderless trolls on, yeah.
That's that's that's fair.
I have a full employment program going over the media matters.
I know we have at least one, maybe two people who are on us, basically.
Full-time at daily wire. So that's, that's exciting.
And I'm glad that we can create jobs in all sectors of the year.
We are creating jobs. I think the obvious way to start this interview.
Cause I want to focus on your book, but I, you know,
of course we have to talk about some of the things.
I don't know if you've heard there's a pandemic and then riots have you.
Haven't heard of that. You're a busy guy. Um, but you know,
I titled my book, don't burn this book. And then the,
basically the day the book came out, every store that had the book was on fire.
Right. But you didn't say don't burn the store to be.
I didn't say don't burn the store that, you know, how's the book.
Now your book is called how to destroy America. Three easy steps.
That how to burn your book. Yeah. That's, that's the basic gist of it.
But of all times America does seem like it's being destroyed right now.
And that's what you titled the book.
And I know a little something about writing. You finished this book when,
how long? December. January. Okay. So actually not that, no.
This is a quick, right.
So what happened is that I gone to Israel for the Jewish holidays.
I came back and I just looked around the country and I thought something is
really, really deeply wrong. I mean,
even more wrong than it has been in prior iterations. And it's,
it's been wrong for awhile. I mean,
there've been things that have been going wrong,
which is why I wrote the previous book, right side of history,
which was the country's kind of falling apart. What do we do?
What common values do we hold? And then I thought, well,
we really need sort of a nation specific book about what we're supposed to be
sharing because obviously there's this widespread perception that we share
nothing. Right? The only thing that we share is an oppressive, evil,
terrible bigoted system. And so I come back from Israel,
I called up my publisher.
I have a two book deal with my publisher and my publisher.
I actually had another book that was slated to come out, uh,
probably at the beginning of next year. And I said,
I want to rush a book out before the election.
I want it to be called how to destroy America in three easy steps.
And I'm going to write it in the next six weeks. And they were like, do I,
do I thank God I, I write incredibly. I used, that was actually a little moan,
Ben Shapiro facts. I used too many, there are many of them, but one of the,
one of the least well-known is I was a ghost writer for many prominent figures
for probably a decade. And that's how I supplemented my income.
So I have something like seven or eight New York times,
best sellers that are not under my own name. I was a great specialist.
Publishers would come to me, there'd be some prominent figure who, you know,
had three weeks to go until deadline. And they'd be like, okay,
well you've got one sentence. What do we do?
And so they turned me over to the book and I'd write an entire book in a month.
So that.
Right.
Can I get you to write a couple of their names on the back of that paper for me.
You later, if it's not in violation by NDAs guys, but in any case, uh, it,
it was written in white heat and it was very easy to write because the structure
of the book is very obvious.
I mean that the basic idea is we don't go that far yet. Okay. Well,
we'll get to it.
I wrote down all six chapters. Cause I want to talk structure.
I think the way you broke it down actually is super interesting. Um,
but before we do full book stuff,
let's just talk about the world as it is at the moment for just show,
Oh, you can curse your brains out, but, but what do you mean you're,
you're you don't curse.
I know, but yeah, I do. If I, if you promise me a bleed, but then I'll curse.
Oh, I, yes. My people will believe it.
I've been waiting for that for a long time Shapiro.
Cause I've heard you say fight off. My guys don't have to bleed my.
They can bleep your privately. And then you're.
Well, as, you know, as you know,
there is a bit of a gap between the public persona and in private cursive
illusory. Cause you know what I said, that's, that's not,
that's not a great shock, but yes.
Okay. So yeah, let's, let's just do it for a little bit. Uh, are we?
Like what the hell is that?
Um, it feels that way. I mean,
it really does feel as though any common bonds that we once shared are basically
disintegrating and that you're being pressured into mimicking the belief that
all those bonds are gone.
So even if you believe that the bonds aren't really afraid and that really,
we should have some stuff in common. If you say that out loud,
you're part of the system, you're part of the white supremacist system. Uh,
and this is it's such dangerous stuff. And as we're sitting here very,
in the last few hours, there was a,
there was a sort of graphic that came out from the national museum of
African-American history and culture, which is a Smithsonian Institute,
taxpayer institution by the government funded by the government.
And it was all about whiteness and the evils of whiteness and among the evils of
whiteness things that we've all integrated into our lives because of the
prevailing system of white supremacy or things like hard work, individualism,
justice, time management, delayed gratification,
science, I'm not kidding. This is all in the document.
These are all of these are all things that are listed as elements of white
supremacy. That must be rejected in order to move forward into a better,
more progressive world. And so all the things that you would think like, yeah,
I, I feel like we should all have this in common. Like, you know, science,
this one, this one we should have in common, there's a whole movement to say no,
no, all of these things are outgrowths of an evil system. And that in turn is a,
the result of an absolutely despicable redefinition of the term
racism when it used to mean in, from virtually all of human history,
but certainly since the 1960s to what it means now. So in the 1960s,
racism was what we all think of racism as believing in the inferiority or
superiority of a particular racial group. Right? Very easy definition.
You can spot it wherever you see it, right? I mean, it's not, not hard.
It's very easily applied definition.
And then there's been an attempt in the last several years to redefine racism to
mean any system that results in racial inequality is itself
racist. And so if you are not seeking the destruction of that system,
you are complicit in racism. And in order to be anti-racism,
you have to seek to destroy that system.
Every system in human history has resulted in inequality of some sort or another
because human beings have different capacities. We make different choices.
You literally tell you telling me we're not all exactly the same.
We don't have all the exact same thoughts and gifts and skills.
You telling me stop being racist. Stop it, stop it.
So the slightly different it wouldn't Kennedy specifically writes this right,
and how to be an anti-racist.
He says literally any system that generates racial inequality is a racist
system.
And so therefore it's not like you're a bad person because you're a racist,
you're just a product of the system or you're upholding the system.
And in order for us to fight that racism, we have to fight the system itself.
And so anything that is part of that system,
anything and everything that is of that system is tainted by racism and must be
ripped down completely. And if you are complicit in the system by,
by doing things like hard work and individualism, you're an assimilationist,
right? This is what,
this is what everyone Kennedy says and how to be an anti-racist.
And Robin's Angela sort of mirrors this, and you're saying yourself,
wait a second.
Are you closing in an awful lot of doors to black Americans and minority
Americans?
Like the pathways to success in a free system are things like hard work,
individual effort, you know, thinking ahead, delayed gratification,
like this is not unique to capitalism or the evil American system. Right.
Right. But, so what are you saying about black pregnancy? It's insane. I mean,
David Duke would write this, right. I mean, you really could. I mean,
David Duke.
Idea that whiteness is about hard work and individual initiative and religious
adherence and families.
Yeah. That's crap. David Duke would. Right. But the.
I'm writing the exact same crap and understand. Yeah.
But all those things are bad. Right.
And if we just got rid of our adherence to these systems,
well then we wouldn't really have to have standards that we hold people to.
And then equality would be the result. I mean, that's insanely dangerous stuff,
but because the charge of racism is the most is the most highly charged charge
you can make against somebody. It's the worst.
You can call somebody in America and for good reason,
because that is an awful thing to be. Right.
And it's an awful thing to say about somebody it's an awful thing to be,
because that is such a highly loaded term.
It's so easy to cuddle people into line. All you have to do is just acquiesce.
All you have to do is be the person who cheers on the guillotines is the
guillotines chop off heads and we'll leave you alone.
Now we're not going to say that you're left alone forever, right?
That this only holds true until the time for the next year. Um, but
I really feel like in this situation, it's very much like the,
the action movie where the bad guy comes to the good guy and he's got some
blackmail to hold over his head. And the good guy says, well,
how do I know you won't use it in the bag that goes,
you don't write that that's, that's the anti-racist movement.
They figure that they can call you a racist and they will hold that over your
head until you acquiesce in all the things.
And if you don't acquiesce in this one little thing,
then you will be ruined and you will be destroyed and you will be targeted as
part of the opposite.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling, checkout our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlists, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.